hey what's going on it's cameron and
this is proflus plus and we're talking
about lights and shadows and for this
more advanced lesson today
i want to
show you
well i want to create like a like a
really simple title sequence
and
i saw something like this similar done
and i can't remember who did it
but uh it was inspiring to me when i
instantly saw that i love being inspired
you know when i see something if it
immediately sticks out to me if
immediately says well i say wow like
that's inspiration to me
and i pull from that so what we're going
to do here is we're going to do like a
simple camera pull out um of this guy
and we're going to add some typography
um around him in 3d space and we're
gonna reveal like a final just title
um it could be anything but we'll
probably just call it title um
and we'll like i said we'll add lights
and shadows to make it more interesting
so
we've learned how to
work with type how to work with
um
texture how to work with 3d cameras and
we're working with lights now so we're
building upon everything we've been
learning so far
so
i'm gonna turn down my music here i've
got some music playing
some m83
if you don't know m83 gotta definitely
check them out this is an older song i'm
listening to so anyways i've got um i've
got a camera here
and i've got a man
here and this is something i pulled off
uh i don't know how you pronounce it but
it's px
h-e-r-e
i always call it sphere.com
[Music]
i don't know if that's how you pronounce
it but it's a
creative commons image
so it's included in the project file
and i've just got black solid here
that's just a 2d layer so i'm going to
lock that that's just my black solid
um sometimes i work with with 100 black
sometimes i work with off black it just
depends
so we've got our guy he's uh he's in 3d
space i've pushed him back here a
thousand pixels just to start
right so
um if i brought him in at zero this is
where he'd be based on my camera but
i pushed him back a thousand pixels
and i've got
a camera here
and i'm just gonna do like a very i'm
gonna set a keyframe here
and in my testing
um
title a i'm not gonna show you that
whenever you see an a and b here on my
timelines that's because the a is
usually my test right so i do a lot of
testing
to figure out what i want to teach you
guys so i put a lot of time into that
and i create these things so i've
created this already
um if i just jump in really fast i don't
want you to see what the images we can
see how many layers are here there's 20
layers well actually there's the title
so there's 20 layers here there was like
50 but i really um
brought down
the complexity of it
because i can't make this into like an
eight-hour tutorial right that's just
it's too much we don't have enough time
for that
so
in my testing i figured out that my
keyframe my camera pulls back here i do
want to add more depth in this version
which versus the one that i did the
testing on
i think on the testing i pull back to
around here
uh so negative 33.96 in pixels but i
want to pull way back
like three times as far so this is
really going to change up
how this looks
um but that's what i want to do and then
when i'm when i'm here
i do want to see some type right this is
where my title is going to be and i'm
just going to call it
title i've actually got my type face
pulled up here it's big castle on fb
again this is an adobe
font
so if you don't have it you can just
install it really easily off adobe type
kit
i also like to
work with
my align tab here so i'm going to align
layers now what's interesting is when
you have a 3d layer
you can't align it for whatever reason
so
unless they fix this in versions that
you're watching
in past versions you haven't been able
to line it so i always align in 2d i
center things up it's just how i work
and then i make it 3d so now it's
three-dimensional
i'm going to bring it really far forward
in z space and i'm actually going to
change the two views
here
so i can see here's my
uh portrait
here's my type and here is my camera
way the heck over here
which you know looking at this now i
think that's this is too much space so
we'll go
let's go negative six maybe
i can deal with this because i want my
portrait guy back here he's going to be
the very far back uh maybe i'll put some
texture behind him
[Music]
but there's going to be things lined up
here in the
middle ground so actually let's just go
even
closer we'll do five thousand negative
five thousand like i said in the
original example i think i was negative
three thousand
so let's bring title
up here i also want to hit a a for my
camera i'm going to turn on depth of
field
and this is one i already played with
a little bit i found that my aperture i
set my focus distance here you can see
this is just
620 620 pixels and my aperture 69.
just based on some testing
since i am rebuilding this there's
always a chance i'm going to change that
stuff but
there you go
let's zoom in here so you can see here
is my focus distance i just want to make
sure that this guy
is closer there so there we go so
there's title
and
in my original example i had title
pretty big i liked it
like that so we'll just
put something like this
and
using lights it's going to
eliminate
how we see things right so right now we
see this guy back here but let's just go
ahead and add a light to this guy
and i think for him we're going to use a
spotlight
and we're going to use falloff
we're going to use shadow darkness
diffusion we're going to turn it up
cache shadows yes
and there you can see immediately that
the guy
the man is lit up the text is not
so go back to two views here and just
see where is this light out here let's
just take a look at where the slide is
okay there we go
so we're gonna push this light
one thing i should mention is if i turn
the light off i don't like
i back this guy up i don't like how this
guy
is cut off here on the side
but that's how the image was right i
didn't have an entire image to work with
so
he's already cut off i think i did a
really rough
cutout job on this guy actually now that
i think about it i think i
was going to show you guys that and i
didn't so let's open up photoshop really
quickly here
and
i'll go ahead and give you this
photoshop file
but when i brought this guy in when i
downloaded them off
sphere.com
if i turn off the
layer mask here you're gonna see
this is what the original image looks
like right so it's pretty cool i like
this texture that's going on around here
um
but
i wanted to be able to see my own
texture in the background so i just did
a really quick lasso
actually i think i did a quick selection
and i just went around and picked the
guy out like this
and could have really feathered the
edges but i didn't because i knew that
he was going to be against a textured
background
i knew that he was going to
be in focus just for a short amount of
time and then be out of focus and
somewhat blurry so
that rough cut out job works for this
right you can see here he is again he's
it's a rough cutout but because i'm
using lights and things like that we're
going to mask some
imperfections of this image
if i was doing this for a client i would
probably take the time i know i would
take the time to
you know spend
15 minutes
intricately cutting him out
probably with the pen tool that's my
kind of go-to
and um just to give it that extra subtle
um you know umph
if that's even a word but
um
just to give it a little bit more detail
that it's just so subtle that a client
or actually the first time you saw this
you didn't notice that he's not a
perfect cutout but just having a little
bit more detail in here would help
but for this example i did want to show
you that you can also get away with
doing like quick selections
in photoshop because we're hiding things
with lights and depth of field and it
can just speed up your workflow
i like to do things as quick as possible
for the most part um in my testings you
know i spend a lot more time testing
building these projects out
uh
just to see what's going to work right
and not work right so
um
yeah i'll quit rambling now
so here's our light again
uh i think for now it's gonna work but
i'm gonna change this to
man
spotlight just so i know because i want
this light to be
just pretty much focused on this guy
okay
so just to give an idea
we could start on
black if i start on
0 here i could actually
keyframe the intensity here
so i could start it
at zero so this is like a real quick
fade up right so we'll start it at zero
and we're at i believe our composition
is 24 frames a second yeah
so we could do like a quick one second
fade up here
so there we are at 100
intensity
and he's kind of pushing back in space
and as he's pushing back in space we're
seeing
other
type and textures moving through space
so i don't want him to stay in focus
you know for too long so by here let's
say he's he's back out
and i don't know that the yellowish
light is
ideal
so let's just go with white because i
like him being in black
but again you can see just just by
looking at this right here if i turn off
my
depth of field let's just turn it off
there's our dude and if i turn the
spotlight off
look how much
nicer this the spotlight makes him right
and i i just brought in a spotlight i
just made it almost 100 it's not 100
white but it's white colored
i just use the default position of the
spotlight
and
the cone
you know i have the cone angle turned
down
uh if it's turned up we can see kind of
the edge there
over in here that we don't want to see
but just adding a simple spotlight
really brings some some interesting life
to this guy
you know something like that
looks really nice so simple spotlight
and then we're controlling him fading in
and fading out with this
simple spotlight
so now let's go ahead and let's add in
maybe let's try adding in the background
i found that i like this chalkboard
texture like this
in the background
so i'm going to bring it behind this guy
go back as far as i need to go and
let's just hit s for scale and let's
scale it up so it fills the frame here
you know it's interesting because i
can't even see the chalkboard because of
this light that's in the scene so if i
turn the light off there's our
chalkboard again so what i want to do
now just so i can see a little bit of
that chalkboard is i'm going to add
another light
and i'm going to make this an ambient
light and this is just going to be my
i'll leave the word ambient in there
ambient fill
again i want to make it more on the
white side definitely not 100 intensity
maybe something really low like 20
percent and when i add this it's going
to affect how this guy is lit
so i'm gonna have to take that into
account
but
yeah
not enough so far something else i'm
going to look at is with this i'm going
to hit a8 i want to make sure that he is
not
casting shadows
he is not casting shadows okay so there
we go so there's cash shadows on
only off
so i just want to make sure he's not
casting any shadows because i don't
see a need for him to cast a shadow onto
my background
what else could i do here i could also
[Music]
just gonna turn this ambient back on hit
aa
just bring it in there a little bit so
that's at 53 let's just try 55 you know
i like to have things
even
now i don't like that
at all okay
excuse me so
maybe what i need to do then is just
turn off this ambient fill
maybe i just make a
another light
that's going to affect the chalkboard
only
and if that's the case i'm going to
actually pull this chalkboard even
further back here
and i'm going to add another
light
and we'll make this
let's make this a point light
and we'll do inverse actually we don't
need any falloff here
i don't need to cast shadows either
and we do need to make sure
that
this light is
behind my guy here
so the light is behind my guide so it's
not lighting my guy right there in front
it's lighting him
behind him he's not lighting them
and
a-a against we have no fall off
one thing to keep in mind too i know i'm
jumping around a lot here but if i turn
falloff off for my man spotlight if i
say none
it is going to light up that chalkboard
back there you can see it's very subtle
but it's just enough fall off so it's
just reaching that guy
and then not going beyond the guy
and not lighting up this chalkboard back
here
so let me go back to my point light here
i'm actually going to try and
change it
to a spotlight with a really wide
angle let's see what that
does let's turn up the intensity
oh it's facing the wrong way
that would help
and my guy is turned to lighten so let's
change him back to normal
for now
i want this to be pretty subtle
and let's change it back to lightning
again
i don't love it when it's lightened so
we'll leave it there
and let's just change spotlight back to
point light just to see
i think i like point light better
just less intensity
change him back to lighten
[Music]
yeah that's nice so it's just a very
subtle background
texture that's there i like it
next let's add another light for the
title here so the title is actually
white text we can see here but it's
black because there's no light for it
okay so ambient fill i'm going to go
ahead and bring up here to the top again
i'm going to turn it on
so i have a feeling we're going to need
some ambient
fill light
i'm also i can see now the chalkboard is
way more uh visible
and it's not big enough
so we're gonna scale it up there we go
[Music]
and let's turn ambient off and be on
you know what let's leave it off for now
in my test i had to use an ambient light
i'll lock the chalkboard
we'll call this
chalkboard light
would unlock that
the man walk i just like to lock these
things
in place
now let's add another actually let's
just duplicate
the man spotlight here
[Music]
duplicate it and let's bring it up here
and we'll change this to
tidal light
and tidal light we're going to bring
way back here so that we can see
the title
and we're going to bring him
left side view here
and bring this guy
down
like so
okay so
the light is not lighting up the title
and
[Music]
it's because i duplicated the light and
we're down to an intensity of zero
that's why so let's just bring the
intensity back up there we go so we'll
just go back up to a hundred
and
[Music]
you can see now
i'll go back to one view here
maybe
you saw from previous lessons i prefer
to use point lights
just because like so you saw there so
there's there's my spotlight see how
it's just kind of cutting off the coning
i could i could expand the cone angle
here easily right and cover this but i
like to work with
less um
options right so it's it's uh less
things to control less like you know
with the spotlight you've got the point
of interest and the position and with
the point light you only have a position
and just changing to point light lights
this up so that's going to work for me
for right now
and we'll go ahead and leave inverse
square clamped on
[Music]
so
there we go
it's looking
starting to get there so next thing
let's do let's bring in some of this
i've got three layers of texture here
okay
and these are just
documents that i downloaded off the
internet creative commons
i was looking for like old
writings old typewriter writings things
like that
and i found things like this so
that's what we're going to use so
nothing i don't want
the writing doesn't have to be anything
that we have to necessarily be able to
read it's just texture that's in there
that's in this piece for us to
add some visual interest okay
so let's
find an area here
one thing that makes this more
challenging is that there's like this
you know cursive writing so like the g
extends down to this line so if i wanted
to get
you know these lines they have these
these letters that extend way down
and i like to make things easy and i
can't just do like a simple mask
so let's actually
just
use the pen tool
[Music]
and let's zoom in here
i think we'll go with this line
there we go
now i want to do is i want this type to
be white versus dark so let's just go to
channel invert
yep
let's also go to color correction black
and white
there we go
and let's go to effect
color correction
levels
and what i want to happen here is i want
the black
to go away in the white to really pop
so to do that
we need to set this to screen
and we need to play with our levels here
i can never remember the right one so we
want to play with with the black level
here okay and probably the gray
it's okay if i see a little bit of this
kind of chalk texture in there that's
okay
because everything is going to be kind
of blurry anyways since we're going to
depth of field on i think
so
let's take this let's make it
three dimensional
and you can see my point of interest is
way down here is when we hit y
and i'm just going to drag this up you
don't have to do this i just like things
to be a little tidier
so if my point of interest is closer to
my center point of the actual part of
the layer i'm using that's going to be
better
for me
and let's zoom back here
and
i just want this guy to be somewhere in
the middle i could go to my two views
again
i could so i'm on the side view here i'm
gonna hit
v for my selection tool
[Music]
oh
you know because i did point i did push
the portrait guy back so at zero
this layer is actually right here um you
know this would work actually but
let me just bring this guy
i don't know i'm just looking at
composition
like
i guess you should understand you know
what makes a good composition and where
things should kind of line up i do teach
that in stylecraft
so there we go so we're kind of flying
past it now as i start adding more
lights and things like that it's going
to get a little bit more
intensive
for the
my computer here but right now we're
still able to kind of scroll through it
pretty quickly
and i'm not going to add a light just
yet to this at this point
let's go ahead and let's just duplicate
this
layer let's go back into our one view
here
and let's solo this layer
and
let's delete this mask
and let's just find a different part
here that we could
sample from
right here
there we go
and we'll zoom back out
and we're going to hit y
for our point of interest or
it's this tool right here it's called
pan behind but it actually controls
our point of interest as well
our are not our point anchor point
sorry two views again and
let's go ahead and bring this guy back
here
maybe up in here
and i could rename these layers to keep
things
a little tidier but this is fine for now
i'm going to kind of keep the text
and an interesting looking kind of block
here
so this is my other line of text here
here's this guy let's go ahead and bring
in
let's actually duplicate
this and i'm the reason i'm duplicating
this is so i don't have to apply all
these effects again and i'm going to go
ahead and bring in
[Music]
i'm alter option clicking dragging
replacing there we go
ooh that looks interesting already
but you can see here
instead of having to apply reapply
invert black and white levels
i just copy and
replace it's easier that's what the
original looks like so invert makes it
white
black and white makes it truly white
and levels
levels is going to be
a little bit different
so if i really want to kind of boost the
the text up the white that's what i'm
going to drag the right side levels here
and it makes me think that maybe i
should just take a look at
this one and maybe intensify it a little
bit
yup
same with this
one cool
and
let's just take a look let's sew this
guy
let's get rid of the mask
i do like this a lot and that's
interesting right there so
let's just do a simple
mask like so
awesome
and
[Music]
why
there we
go
two views and
i like to kind of just position
elements around and then come back after
my camera i see you know i'm flying
through it i see things
kind of reposition at that point
maybe something like that and let's
duplicate this one again
and
[Music]
you can tell i really like to work in
one view
that's cool right there just that
boom
and
why again you don't have to move the
anchor point
like this but i like to
now you can see here with the whites
being drug you know
taking the slider to the left here it's
making this texture inside this image
come out too much and i don't want to
see
too much of that so i have to be careful
of that
that'll work
i also don't want to be too close to
my title here
because by the time i get to this point
i just want to see the title
again you can see this one there's too
much texture happening here
so this is a tricky one because if i get
rid of this texture it's getting rid of
this as well
let's forget to see about this one
hmm
let's just go ahead and keep this for
now
something i could do here is i could
feather
quite a bit
and kind of
that helps a little bit but you can see
what is this back here
is that my chalkboard
okay so there's a layer right here
okay that's that so let's feather this
one
let's bring this guy up
okay i want to bring this guy
back and z
that's looking kind of cool
save
and i'd probably go ahead and turn my
aaa camera depth of field on
and let's hit u for position
we're going to make this guy ease in
here
and the reason i'm doing this is because
here i'm at um
i'm 10 seconds into my animation right
so if this is like a title
i don't want to go take a full 10
seconds to get to this end title because
then it leaves me like what do we have
here
so that's 12 seconds so we're at 10
let's actually make it even
let's go right here to 10 seconds even
so if i if i'm fully pulled out with my
camera at this point that's 10 seconds
the end of my timeline here is 12
because my entire
title sequence here is 12 seconds
i don't want to just give it two real
quick seconds to read
because we've been seeing so much
information flying past us visually
we're looking at everything we want to
have some time to really settle on this
title whatever this title is so i want
to
move
my camera in quicker to this end point
so easy ease by default is going to stop
you know it's going to default to this
value which is what 33
let's just take it
i think in my testing i was around 60
[Music]
so that would probably work right in
there i've got depth of field on
now again we can see this text here and
we don't want to see that text by the
time we're to our title by the time i
get to my title i just want to be
focused on that title
let me save here i'm going to
okay ambient is not turned on
there's the ambient so we need some
light
to only affect our
textures here so what is the lighting
title okay so our tidal light is the one
that's lighting up
all this back here so what we need to do
here is we need to go aa on our title
light
we could change this back to spot or we
could just play around with our inverse
square clamped here
um i'm going to play around with radius
i'm going to bring it way down you can
see as i'm bringing it down everything
back here is going away
and but now our title is going away so
we want to make sure our titles
lit up there
you know it doesn't have to be perfectly
dark back there
but i could also even add another light
back here that
and let's try that let's just add let's
duplicate the title light and let's call
this
negative light
and this one we're obviously going to
make it negative
to pull light away right
but to do that we also need to be past
our title here so we don't want that to
affect our title so let's go past the
title
so we're just inside the title here and
you can see
it's doing its job so if i turn it off
there's
the text
there's without the text now the trick
here is to have it just enough
because like right here i want to see
the texture so i could do is actually
set a keyframe here
so let's make this zero so it's not
affecting it's not taking light away
but as it moves past
this title
there it's pulling
light away
maybe
i'm gonna have it coincide with this guy
back here
[Music]
so let's maybe do something
but not to be perfect
looks pretty cool
save that
and let's go ahead and
let's actually duplicate this guy again
[Music]
now let's bring in our third texture
which is this guy
and let's just solo that
let's take the mask let's delete the
mask
and
if i turn if i had a aaa and i say
accept lights off
now i can fully see this so
even though we're only soloing this
layer because lights are in our our
timeline they still affect the layer
that's soloed so lights are always on
so let's save that
and for this one we don't
i don't think we want to invert this one
let's just turn off our effects here
this is pretty big image
you know might be kind of cool to see
just kind of looking at this this is
kind of an interesting block right here
and if i'm not totally sure on the part
of the image i want to use i'll do
things like this where i'll just draw a
rough mask um you know
obviously this isn't something i
probably want
because of this vertical line here i
don't love the way that looks but
if i decide to use this
i can always refine my mask so if i
invert this
okay
black and white
yeah and then levels
so we need to let's actually reset the
levels here
i need to get rid of
that texture in there
and let's just try feathering
a large amount here
and we're out of focus here
and
my anchor points way up there
so i definitely don't like those
vertical lines there
that's not too bad it might be usable
depending on where
we position everything here
no i'm not a fan i can already tell it's
because i'm cutting too much off here so
let's solo that again
take the mask
do that here
and let's just look around inside this
image here so i think
i think previously maybe i used
this right here so let's just
take the pen tool
and
[Music]
let's do that
yeah
and we'll unsolve that and we're going
to take y to move our anchor point up
here
so maybe somewhere in here
let's actually back it all the way up
here because i want to see a little bit
of text
maybe in here
so go two views here
something like this
yeah so it's just on the edge here
so that our first focus is on this guy
he's the important character in the show
and then we start to see some additional
text come in here i don't like
the
texture there so we need to get rid of
that texture so let's
play around here this
and there are different ways you can
remove
you know portions of this texture you
could do
luma keying
i just find that levels
curves
is a quicker way
now you can see here now the text all of
a sudden looks way blown out compared
to the image so you have to keep things
like that in mind so i was i got the
texture removed but all of a sudden the
white in the text was way too powerful
compared to the rest of it
and i'm gonna just reposition some
things here
so elements aren't competing
too much
it's also okay just to see
um portions of elements right we want to
see the entire
piece
this guy
is really far over here
don't need to be that far over
maybe something in here
i'm actually going to move this guy over
here
now it's funny because now this texture
we just brought in is so powerful it's
still there
even with the lights
off so let's make sure it's accepting
lights
it's not accepting lights
there we go that's why
so now you can see this guy's not even
being lit up at all
because he's not accepting lights and
he's too far away from other lights so
let's add
a light
we'll keep it a point light and this
will be called
texture light
actually we'll call it
word
texture
light and we're going to say one just in
case we need to add extras
and i actually want to turn uh they
don't need to cast shadows
now you can see i added that and look
what it did to the guy
way too much light there
so let's take the intensity down
let's find our texture here's our
texture right here that's not being lit
there's our light
so with light
without
so you can see the lights affecting the
man it's also affecting the the words
here so let's back it up just a little
bit more here
take them over to the right side
and then again i'll turn the light off
on just to see how he's affecting
the entire composition uh he's affecting
the man but it's not too much
but i may turn it down just a little bit
more
turn it off
on something i could play with again is
the fall off
and then off on off on so now the light
is only affecting this texture here i
think i'm going to duplicate this light
bring it back
and have it affect
some of these other textures here
not super happy with the placement of
elements so i'm redoing them a little
bit here just
for my eye just to see what i like
that's looking a little bit better i'm
going to save that
and i want to add
a couple more elements here
and those are
right here under footage
i've got two footage layers here this
one is a
i believe it's a free texture from
is it premium bead it's all linked to it
in the description below it's a
volumetric light with some dust moving
through it and you can go to their
website and you can download this
texture i can't give it to you
i can't redistribute it but i also have
another one here and this is air
particles wendy and this is from our
friends at vf action vfx
they've got amazing stuff i'll link to
their site as well if you want to pick
up any of their
product packs but you're going to get
this
element here
they create just different uh
footage
for compositing in visual effects and
it's great for like
visual effects shots but it's also great
for like motion graphics stuff like this
so let's bring both of these in but
we'll start with
this subtle dust and what this is going
to do with the volumetric light is it
puts a nice atmosphere
into our piece here
and make it three-dimensional
and we're going to pull it forward in
space
let's just kind of figure out what's
going on here
let's go back to two views
let's tell it to ignore the lights
there it is
and i need to also set it to screen
there we go so it's a nice you can see
there's a really nice volumetric feel to
it
and let's just see here
yeah that looks really nice
now the only thing that doesn't look
nice is when it gets
out here
and we're just gonna solve that by
scaling it up now remember i probably
will
add a light to this and we we won't see
it by the time it hits this point but
just to be safe i scaled it up
so let's save this
we're at full res here let's go ahead
and preview this and see how let's see
how it looks
okay so here's our playback
it's looking pretty good
there's a few things i want to change
about it
for one i don't love the
like the atmospheric light here looks
pretty nice
it does need to fade away i believe
i want tidal to be more on its own
but it looks nice
adds a little bit of depth to it uh some
of this type works some of it doesn't
this line doesn't work the rest of the
stuff right here works so let's move on
let's wrap up this video and let's move
on to part two
[Music]
you